[Music]
eevee on standby
five four three two
one go a very good morning ladies and
gentlemen and welcome to the design
education summit
this year it is the very first time the
summit is conducted
in a fully virtual format the speakers
around the world will be
sharing about topics that revolve around
rethinking design projects in a
post-pandemic world
using technology to enhance creativity
in
education and designing learning
experiences
using play all of you have gathered here
today with a common vision and goal
to better prepare our students for a
world that has been disrupted by kobit
19.
against this backdrop we need to prepare
our young to be adaptable
nimble and innovative problem solvers
and in this respect design as a
discipline and way of thinking
has much to offer design thinking is
powerful and i think the reason it is
is you have an effective fluidity
between
both the the traditional knowledge and
skills and the
um more open-ended creativity and by
going back and forth between these two
knowing that both of them are essential
never be held ransomed by failure
because i think in your lifetime you're
gonna work on
let's say one thousand projects one
field project one over one thousand
what kind of percentage is nothing
[Music]
design is the thinking process behind
infection
it needs an imaginative spirit to be
able to connect the doors between what
is what exists and what they want to eat
creative's problem-solving education
is one where we have an attitude of yes
future thinking
optimistic integrated in partnership
with parents
having time and space for reflection
knowing every child has gifts
relational and less transactional where
we treat
need finding brainstorming and testing
as serious
skills all to equip our children with
the ability to create
which is the highest order skill of all
because the 21st century
is the century for design
you